stocamine est devenue le premier centre
en france de stockage souterrain de
déchets ultimes
au départ le site de stocamine dans la
banlieue de mulhouse semblait être une
bonne idée
la solution pour stocker des déchets
ultimes comprendre des déchets qu'on ne
sait pas recyclés résidus de mercure
cyanure arsenic ou amiante
voici donc ces déchets ultimes enfouis à
plus de 500 mètres de profondeur ce
stockage fait réagir des militants
écologistes
les déchets se trouve sous la plus
grande nappe phréatique d'europe
mais la direction du site à l'époque se
veut rassurante
à leur arrivée les déchets pour promis à
une analyse post prix est inflammable et
par liquides organiques
tous ces produits sont refusés refusé
pourtant en 2002 le pire arrive
lincendie du centre de stockage de
masques moi je débute jeudi un jour on
va sauter lincendie marque du jour au
lendemain la raie de stocamine et créer
une nouvelle polémique
faut-il extraire par précaution les 44
mille tonnes de déchets des gens ou
une première décision entre 2014 et 2017
les déchets jugés les plus dangereux
sont évacuées au total le déstockage
aura duré deux ans de plus que prévu
108 mineurs se sont succédé sur 25
postes ce qui témoigne de la difficulté
et du danger de ces opérations
mais après ces opérations il reste
encore plus de 40 mille tonnes de
déchets sous terre des déchets que les
militants écologistes voudraient voir
retirer dans leur intégralité
une opération jugée trop dangereuse par
la direction de stocamine
on va rencontrer des terrains qui sont
fermés sur l'aide des chats et des
déchets qu'il faudra extirper au forceps
et et là on aura des prises de risques
pour les opérateurs en 2018 en tout cas
un rapport parlementaire préconise
d'extraire tous les déchets restants
mais l'état renonce à le faire colère
des élus locaux
ces formes d' insulte aux citoyens c'est
encore une décision prise par paris et
par l'administration centrale
près de vingt ans après l incendie
évacuées ou non les déchets restants
n'est toujours pas actée sur twitter la
ministre de l'ecologie barbara pompili
là sur la décision sur l'avenir des
déchets du site de stocamine je ne la
prendrai pas seul depuis un bureau à
paris
une décision attendue d'ici à la fin du
mois de janvier
[Musique]